she's perfect me in every way I've never
been so happy and I feel so lucky I love
this man he is definitely the one he's
my best friend my everything there's no
one I trust more no one I've been ever
so close to in my life and I just feel
so blessed every single day it sounds
like what I say in my head over and over
and over again every single morning when
I wake up just totally grateful if there
a ring on that left hand what what's the
deal this is actually a gift from my
friend Rosalina this is not an
engagement ring
yeah what is not yet me no fine now are
you guys that serious you seem very in
love you can't keep your hands off each
other
absolutely
soul mate for sure
what is it about each other that means
you both know slowly
you wake up with a smiling you fall
asleep with a smile being best friends
and finally finding someone that I love
and trust and know that I want to spend
the rest of my life with it's the best
feeling in the world when did you know
she was the one from the moment I laid
eyes on her eight years ago at the
Chateau a lot of patients
I mean did you know he was the one name
Bank I met him we met eight years ago at
the Oscars the shot to marvel he walked
in the room I've never seen him before
and I said that's the most gorgeous man
I've ever seen in my life we started
talking and from that moment I always
had a huge crush on him y'all are about
to make me start believing in love again
I didn't believe it existed either
collabs with them it does exist and love
at first sight does exist how is wedding
planning are you nervous are you
bridezilla are you chill cuz you throw
an epic party you're know how to throw
down I've been doing this a long time
I've thrown some pretty incredible
parties a wedding is totally different
though so you see yourself is like a
princess or do you see yourself as like
a sexy a little bit of both I think for
sure I'm gonna have at least three
dresses I love it congratulations
I just have never felt happier in my
life I feel like I'm glowing
feel
like a woman it's like an adult like I
don't know it's feel like my life was
crying just starting what about her you
know I think there's there's a couple
sides the the public side that I think a
lot of people seen and then sitting with
her over the years you see this like
pretty thoughtful really smart
businesswoman side what is it that you
love about I think she's one of the most
intellectual women I've ever met
and just taking advice from her in every
aspect I think the better question is
what don't you like and that's there's
nothing so marry this man Paris okay
Souls so when were to be thinking summer
wedding are you ready
definitely this year we need to plan it
first we have the engagement party the
bridal party and then the wedding we're
still picking a date that's perfect for
everyone in the family my brother is
getting married in June so
separate a few more months after that I
have that ring accessory now yeah so
beautiful thank you so much can we talk
sweating a little bit just the guest
list do you have any ideas yet I feel
like you've been hanging out with the
Kardashians lately we saw you at dinner
with Paris Jackson last night all my
girls will be invited so right now we're
just picking out the dress location
there's so much to plan so I just can't
wait it's a really exciting time for
everyone you're gonna do it so big that
you're gonna have multiple dresses what
do you think I love outfit changes I
think I have so many amazing designer
friends who are sending me all these
designs so there's gonna be a couple
outfit changes for sure thinking
princess dress are you thinking tight I
love Grace Kelly
Elizabeth Taylor thought there were such
beautiful brides my sister was the most
gorgeous bride in the world just like a
princess so would you ever do a TV show
with Chris like a reality docu we've
been getting a lot of offers to do that
so right now I'm just deciding if I want
to do that or no
but maybe it'd be hard on a relationship
- it is but I've done it for a long time
it'd be new for him because he's never
done something like that he's more of an
actor so it'd be something new for him
definitely can you tell me about your
wedding dress I heard that you picked
one is that true I have picked one and
my sister told me it's important for it
to be a surprise okay like don't show
anyone but her of course she actually
told me last week that she's gonna be
the maid of honor how'd you ask her it's
just obvious she's my best friend she's
like my other half I love her so much
so of course she was animated on earth
and I was hers as well is she planning a
bachelorette party yes she is in the
process of that so we are trying to
figure out where to do it
you're still planning the wedding you
pushed it back a little bit what's left
to be done I just have so much going on
I'm releasing my 24th fragrance platinum
rush someone going to entire tour this
year so we're gonna push it's next
year's we have more time to plan take
time to plan perfection
[Music]